اختفاءه عشرات الاطفال من طالب اللجوء
كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق الذي تديره
وزاره الداخليه يثير صدمه كبيره في
الاوساط السياسيه والحقوقيه في بريطانيا
مع كشف تحقيق انما يقارب من 80 طفلا لا
يزالنا في عداد المفقودين
واقعه تقشعر لها الابدان بالرمي من
التحذيرات المتكرره لوزاره الداخليه بان
الاطفال اللاجئين غير مسحوبين بدويهم
مستهدفون من قبل الشبكات الاجراميه وربما
يتم الاتجار ببعضهم بعيدا عن الفندق الذي
ياويههم
روعه
لا تتوقع ان يحدث في اي مكان يعني هيك في
مكان معين هنا في المملكه المتحده
وتحديد مكانهم ومعرفه سبب اختفائهم
اطفال اللاجئين التي وصفها احد الموظفين
مع شركه لحمايه الاطفال متعاقده مع وزاره
الداخليه سجلت ايضا في فنادق اخرى ماذا
دفع القيد العماليه في مجلس برايتون الى
المطالبه باجراء تحقيق عاجل في الاطفال
المفقودين
الاطفال في امان وحصلنا ضمنات بان كل شيء
على ما يرام ومن ثم بدانا نسمع باشاعات ان
الامور ليست كذلك
وكشفت بيانات رسميه قبل اربعه اشهر انني
222 من طالب اللجوء فقدوا من فنادقات تشرف
عليها وزاره الداخليه وحينها اعترف
الوزراء بانه ليست لديهم فكره عن مكان
وجودهم
المعارضه انتقدت وزاره الداخليه لاخفاقها
في حمايه سلامه الاطفال او قمع العصابات
الاجراميه التي تعرضهم للخطر وطلبت بوضعه
ترتيبات جديده لحمايتهم على وجه السرعه
والكشف عن عدد المفقودين والاجراءات التي
تم اتخاذها للعثور عليهم من مدينه
بريطانيا العربيه